What has been the biggest challenge that you've had to face in your skating career?
I think last year is one of the hardest obstacles that I've overcome...
...in that, I was injured and I was being a teenager and rebellious.
And everything combined wasn't good for me, but...
...I think I've been able to overcome that.
So this year, I'm gonna be even harder on myself and push myself to reach my dream.
What are you hoping for in 2010?
Well, definitely,...
...I would love to go to the Olympics...
...and it would be an honor to represent my country,...
...but in the long run...
...if I do all the best I can in my training every day,...
...I think I'll be satisfied with any result.
Well, thank you so much for talking to us today.
Thank you!
I'm Ella Morton and you've been watching Rocketboom.